le ministre d outre mer doit arriver
aujourd'hui aux antilles françaises
rencontre prévue en martinique et en
guadeloupe
sébastien lecornu arabi un débat sur
cette île dont la question d'une plus
large autonomie et il a salué à retour
au calme cette nuit mais les
manifestations anti passé anti
obligation vaccinale se poursuivent
comme celle d'hier à pointe à pitre lee
26 prix cas et l'hindi péclard
les annonces des agences
gouvernementales n'ont pas suffi pour
faire redescendre la pression sur lille
6 au rythme du mas musique emblématique
du carnaval guadeloupéen que des
milliers de manifestants se rassemblent
et défilent pacifiquement afin de
montrer une fois de plus l'union qui
règne à travers ce peuple pendant la
grève
plus il y aura de personnes justement
qui est qu'il me dise qu'on compte
aimions sûr entendu maintenant c'est
vraiment même les citoyens même c'est ça
s'arrête plus aux syndicats ça sera plus
voilà c'est un certain âge organise
maintenant c'est tous les citoyens qui
sont dedans une mobilisation qui va au
delà de l'obligation vaccinale sur une
île où le chômage atteint les 19 au sens
où le manque de fierté robinet et où la
jeunesse est souvent décriée au final
c'est toutes les classes de la
population qui se retrouvent dans les
revendications à l'ordre du jour moi
c'était un mouvement il est important ce
n'est pas difficile parce que c'est
beaucoup de sacrifices
des habits c'est à dire forcément les
vous comparez ex terrasse la trêve mais
ce sacrifice qui paupières qui sont
nécessaires je bosse
les négociations se poursuivent tant
bien que mal toutefois une sortie de
crise sur les conditionner à des mesures
fortes par le gouvernement et par les
élus locaux reste à savoir si les
nombreuses questions comme celle de
l'autonomie de la guadeloupe permettent
d'enclencher ou de réenclencher un
dialogue serein entre la guadeloupe et
le gouvernement